Speaker 1: Florida is at the center of a
Republican civil war that I absolutely love.
Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis is almost
certainly going to win reelection. It's just what
the polls say and everybody should get out there
and vote for Charlie Crist. But in all likelihood,
the winner is going to be Ron DeSantis. Donald
Trump has announced a series of rallies, including
in Florida, in support of 2022 candidates. He is
doing a rally in Florida with Marco Rubio, who's
running for reelection to the Senate. But Ron
DeSantis is conspicuously excluded from that. We
know what this is all about, my friends. This is
a snub because Trump is furious with the Santos.
DeSantis, when asked, has not ruled out running in
2024 for the Republican presidential nomination,
even if even if Donald Trump wants the nomination
as well. Donald Trump expects unending loyalty
from other Republicans. What Trump wants the
Santos to have said is, I won't challenge Donald
Trump. This nomination is Trump's if he wants it.
If he doesn't, then I'll think about my political
future. DeSantis hasn't done that. And why hasn't
DeSantis done it? Well, if you look at the betting
markets, you see that DeSantis is essentially
running tied with Donald Trump. When you ask
people, who do you believe will be the Republican
nominee? These aren't polls in the polls. Trump
is still doing much better. These are betting
markets. DeSantis and Trump have been right,
neck and neck for a couple of months at this
point in time. DeSantis knows he is positioned
to maybe be the Republican presidential nominee,
which would be a big boon for him, without a
doubt. And this is making Trump furious. Politico
reports Trump to hold rally in Florida with Rubio,
but not DeSantis. The apparent snub are angered
some people within DeSantis orbit who complained
that the Florida governor's team was not informed
of the rally prior. It is abundantly clear what
is going on here. Donald Trump correctly and
accurately sees Ron DeSantis as a threat to
Trump's potential. Desire to be the Republican
nominee in 2024. And so this civil war is growing
and growing and growing. I've told you before the
numerous reports of Donald Trump privately fuming
at Ron DeSantis, and increasingly we have seen
Ron DeSantis publicly distance himself from Donald
Trump when it comes to Florida's COVID response
and other things. This is a great thing. This is
a great thing. The more strife there is from now,
because lesson 2024 starts in 12 days after the
November midterm, the more strife there is between
these folks. Leading up to the primary, I believe,
the more they will weaken each other and hopefully
hurt themselves in the eventual general election
of 2024. We will have plenty of time to
discuss that, but you really love to see it.